si vous trouvez qu'il y a beaucoup de
moustiques cette année vous avez raison
des jeux on verra ce qu'il faut pour
nous protéger
c'est sûr car on a quand même beaucoup
de c'est surtout le soir le début de
l'été et éperlecques que les années
précédant même à la maison
on le voit dans tous dans nos cours de
maisons y en a vraiment plus le baby
boom chez les moustiques se mesurent
concrètement on a beaucoup plu il ya des
endroits qu'on camp jusqu'à huit fois
plus cette année un couvert de neige
il paraît important que perdurer de
façon très tardive et donc sous couvert
d'un âge là bas fait d'une multitude de
petites mares et et voilà l'endroit
idéal que nous nous sic se développe ça
va varier selon les conditions
d'humidité et les moustiques peuvent
survivre un mois deux mois et même
jusqu'à trois hommes ont donc les
moustiques qui sont sortis au cours des
derniers jours dernières semaines
risquent de nous accommoder encore
quelques semaines
c'est ce qui fait qu'ils sont si
nombreux à nous piquer 7 à leurs ardeurs
ces pièges installés dans des dizaines
de villes du québec et de l'ontario
servent à capturer des moustiques
l'entreprise gdg environnement effectué
des traitements avec un larvicide
biologique et mesure assidûment les
populations de maringouins il y à plus
de 60 espèces de moustiques dans le sud
du québec
j'ai environ une quinzaine d'espèces la
maman pète rhee que j'ai tout densifier
puis j'ai séparé par petits paquets
stéphanie du ch elle voit des milliers
de spécimens par jour des fois je peux
avoir je sais le thorax l'abdomen puis
je veux savons c'est quoi le ce qu'elle
trie avec ses collègues correspond à ce
qui tourne autour des citoyens il y a
les espèces du printemps et les premiers
moustiques d'été si justement du culex
lee culex une variété de moustique sont
analysés parce qu'ils transmettent le
virus du nil au québec c'est le culex
qui les intéressent beaucoup d entre eux
mais là j'en ai pas beaucoup fatigués
ils arrivent habituellement en juillet
et en août des espèces vectrices bon
choix se développer dans les milieux
artificiel les petits objets qui
ramassent de l'eau n'est pas de quel
endroit qui gardent lost and young
ce jour là au minimum de séjour ça va
être suffisant pour créer une nouvelle
génération moustiques
il faut donc éviter les accumulations
d'eau stagnante et protéger sa peau il
faut que je me mette parce que j'ai
quelques piqûres que je prends dans mon
jardin je les attire pas mal je peux pas
rester immobile longtemps on sait que
les femelles sont attirés par le co2
l'octane hall et l'acide lactique
produit à l'effort c'est difficile de
faire une généralité dire que les
moustiques à mieux tel type de personnes
non faut penser que 60 espèces et ses
espèces leçons sont aussi associés des
niches très particulière mais un
désordre d'activités différentes
difficile aussi de prédire la suite pour
l'été c'est la pluie qui rend les
conditions favorables à leur
développement
la canicule étant le pire ennemi des
moustiques ici and with despatie radio
canada montréal